we would have a trouble with pirates is  September some countries been giving  them safe haven  they'll take hostages or go for our  Rovers it's like the Wild West out there  it's your first time in the war zone  three years over the Arctic Circle and a  heck of a lot of Army Navy games I guess  there's not much you have a say right  well there's almost a full moon a large  stretch of the fosters real black so  pseudo  [Music]  the Big Blue Marble  [Music]  Rover seven confirming settings carry  two Niner Oh  and we have what looks like unidentified  Rovers approaching our position possible  pirate activity  okay  we're not clear I repeat we are not  clear we have multiple enemy craft in  pursuit  [Music]  you  you